one of the things we've really focused
on here is what I'm now calling and what
Maajid Nawaz has coined as the
regressive left that there there are
people I come from the progressive world
that that's where I've been for these
last couple years and it's only really
in the last six months that I've had my
own awakening that I realized it was my
guys it's my guys on the Left that are
trying to silence people like you and
silence people like Sam Harris and and
Majin and all of this and and I've had
Sam and I've had Majid on and I include
you in that and I think partially I
think that Sam said that part or Majid
said the part of his awakening was after
a debate that he had with you what do
you make of this coming from the left
because the left is supposed to debate
ideas right we're supposed to be about
ideas free thought and yet it's those
very people who are trying to silence
you I'm amazed by this I think what I've
seen and I could be wrong is that what
the left does is they put all the
emphasis on justice the concept of
justice and maybe what the right rather
classical liberals because those are the
people I identify with and in the u.s.
they are called conservatives sometimes
libertarians but what classical liberals
do is they put the emphasis on freedom
and I was exposed to these concepts
between say 1995 when I go to the
University of Leiden until 2000 and 2001
something happiness that makes me intent
on testing these ideas and what I have
discovered like many people before me
and I think you realize as you grow yeah
is that you know there is no justice
without freedom and so if if you accept
and that is freedom from coercion
freedom from being forced into doing
something you don't want to do or using
the tools of states to make individuals
do something they don't want to do or
the government failing at you know
having one individual take the freedom
of the other individuals but if you have
no freedom then you
have no justice yeah so so I'm with you
on just a secondary right so what do you
make of the tactics that they use
because there's been so much we've
talked about it so much but so much
lying and smearing about people's views
including your own even when I when I've
just tweeted that I'm having you on the
show
fortunately because we've built
something good here I think you know 80%
of it was positive but a lot of people
she's racist I mean they're telling me
that you are racist so what what do you
make of the tactics that they're using
because I do think they think they're
doing something lofty they think they're
they're helping the downtrodden or
something like that when in actuality
they're strengthening the very people
that they should by definition be
against and I think that is because if
you put the emphasis on justice you are
by definition going to start talking
about groups and collectives groups and
productive czar abstracts you belong to
a group for you know a short period of
time you're a member of whatever you are
collective you are a member of a certain
amount of time but really all the time
you are an individual so the basic
arguments I used to have with the left
and I started out in the Netherlands was
okay so you want to protect the culture
and the religion of this collective and
this collective is saying if we don't
practice our religion the way we used to
back at home we are just not happy we
feel deprived we feel persecuted we
don't feel at home and that has all
kinds of a psychological effect on the
entire group but what about the
individual what about the individual
girl who's removed from school
what about individual girl who's forced
into a marriage which is consistently
raped she can't reach out to her parents
because they could hide in that
situation her husband thinks he has a
higher what about that individual right
what about the individual right to say I
don't want to do this I want to do
something else and you're forcing this
individual into doing that and these
constitutions in Liberal countries is
all about recognizing that individual
freedom and aspiring to protect it as
much as possible and so what I tell my
left-wing friends and I have a lot of
them because a lot of them have good
intentions and they're progressive and
they want to stand up for the poor the
downtrodden filled
same way yeah it's just take them back
to that unit that they can empathize
with if you're gay and you're on the
left and on the one hand you belong to a
movement you're fighting for the right
in America to marry but on the other
hand you're also fighting for the right
of some minority collective to do
whatever they want to the individual
members shouldn't you be thinking about
the plight of the individual members
those who can talk voice their wishes
and those who if they do have to deal
with consequences so die and I'm not
talking about death and threats I'm
talking about your father looking you in
the eye and telling you're no longer my
daughter I disown you you should control
yourself up in the mosque you are not
invited to so you're shunned yeah and
think of the psychological impact of
that on the individual who chooses to
have a lifestyle that is not in sync
with seventh-century lifestyle right and
and that lifestyle whether they're gay
or or just a woman is what is what the
progressives should always be fighting
for and that's the ultimate irony in
this that's the ultimate irony if these
women that I I mean this is my
background I wanted to be free to
determine my own destiny I didn't want
to marry the man I was forced in to
marry I wanted to find my own mate in
life I wanted to work and I wanted to
finish my education and I'm still that's
going to bring shame on us now with the
emphasis on us that is the group the
collective so it's always you the
individual the unit and you're
constantly being told you're so selfish
you're bringing down the whole family
the whole clan the whole group and in
and here's the irony I think it used to
be the left that would take up the
defense of the week and now
unfortunately we live in a time when it
is the left that has decided to define
weak units as groups not individuals so
so what can we do what what yeah so what
can we do people people in the public
sphere with a voice that care
out people on the left they're not even
people on left to care about liberal
values yeah what can we do because when
I see the tactics and they the way they
treat you guys yeah I even I've asked
this to Sam and Marge and I said you
know there must be this piece of you
that wants to get out and that's why I
asked you to and I partly think that the
reason that they do it is they want to
do enough damage to you guys and people
like you so that everyone else it's not
about you you know what I mean like
they'll get rid of you you'll just say
okay I can't do this anymore and that
but it's the chilling effect for
everyone beneath you so how do we fight
this it's about their utopia I think
what we have to do is we have to expose
the fact that they are after a utopia
this whole justice thing the you know
life would be wonderful if we had Sharia
law all of us let's just uncover their
message really would we and I think if
you are a liberal you have to revisit
the basic principles of liberalism and
it was about individuals that is how the
aristocracy was put in its place back
then when there was you know I have all
of these rights because I happen to
belong to this family and you're all
serfs and you serve us as aristocrats
because you happen to belong to that
collective wasn't about that it is about
the individual freedom when it was about
you know fighting slavery you had to
recognize the other person who was the
slave as a fellow human being and as an
individual fighting for women's rights
you had to recognize women as fellow
individual human rights in human beings
and the whole concept of human rights is
based on the individual and the freedom
of the individual and we know that we
are social animals and are social
animals and as individuals within our
families and within our communities
within our workplace we have to
negotiate that sweet spot that space
where you can say I can be me and and
this is how I can serve my community and
this is how my community can serve me
but all of that is not going to work if
individual liberty is compromised and
unfortunately the people who have
inherited these system
America Europeans other free countries
they're compromising that because they
think it's so you know is this
collective or that collective and this
story that narrative it is they think
it's they think it's a lofty goal
somehow but I do I do think do you sense
that the tide is turning I feel like you
know the social justice warrior thing
and this whole movement I feel like it's
been gaining strength for the last five
years but I do think partly because of
Charlie Hebdo and sort of the general
absurdity of so much of it online and
you know Brandeis University saying that
they're not going to give you an
honorary Doctorate I mean the height of
absurdity to not give you an honorary
Doctorate after they said they would do
it that I do sense that the tide is
turning am I just being optimistic there
or do you feel that I think what we are
seeing is more and more confrontations
that really pronounced this this
struggle and I I think one of them is
Israel versus the Arab Muslim world here
is a liberal country it's a democracy
for goodness sake yeah and and we find
Outsiders telling them what they and
they can and can't do who look you know
in the United States of America if we
had people throwing rocks at us right
knifing us if you had the leadership of
the opposition saying you know take a
knife take a car take whatever weapon
you can't go after them we would find it
completely unacceptable and deal with it
appropriately but when Israel does it we
demonize and vilify Israel so in a weird
way it's one but that's one example yeah
and then we have more examples and
you've mentioned magic and myself and
all the other what I I don't know what
is the right time to use Muslim
performers Muslim modifiers Muslim
heretics I think that is the right word
heretic is you're on the inside you
start to ask questions and then you're
vilified and shunned by this group
because they don't want to change or
because they have an agenda for Sharia
and the Caliphate in Jihad and you stand
up to that and then they go after you so
we're seeing so many of these
confrontations on so many different
levels
and I think the mistake is that you know
if you're a socialist in the United
States of you know you're Bernie Sanders
and you're running for president and
you're Donald Trump in your hand for
president you can say the most
ridiculous things in the world you know
nobody's going to kill you and nobody
expects you to be killed and if you are
attacked if any violence against these
two right now these two extremes the
American population is going to meet
that with such rejection and it's going
to be reviled and we have to teach the
rest of the world that it is possible to
disagree and to disagree radically but
not use violence unless violence is used
so that's an interesting thought because
we always think or I think we that our
system is so broken here our political
system is so broken and we can't get
things done properly in our discourse is
so silly in cable news but actually the
way you just said that that look you
have these two people who are couldn't
be further from each other Trump and
Sanders the ultimate capital is the
ultimate socialist and yet they're not
there is no threat there's no credible
threat to their lives right so that does
show that we have something pretty good
about our Western society I know it's
not cool to say that but that's the
truth right that's the truth and it goes
even more than that we also expect them
to shake hands onstage
we expect them to be civil to one
another and they can disagree as much as
they'd like but you know why is the
general public say the establishment
Republicans why are they angry with
Donald Trump I don't think it's because
of his ideas sometimes it's because of
the way he speaks that goes a little too
far it gets too close to you know
uncivilized behavior a violent behavior
let's no to do that there is there is a
culture here where yes people are
violent there's a lot of there are a lot
of guns out there and people use these
guns but mainstream Americans expect
mainstream Americans to behave in a
certain way and it's not a culture that
says let's not disagree we know we all
disagree yeah say the system is broken
or it's the human being that's fragile
we disagree what we have is a system
where you can have the
disagreements and these discussions and
you can change your mind or you can go
as radical as you please but you are not
expected to use violence and the
government is there to protect you and
with people putting question marks on
the First Amendment there are two
different things is one part of it is
you know we can disagree with one
another as much as we like but there's a
system here there's an infrastructure
that allows us to disagree with one
another without the use of violence if
you start putting question marks on the
First Amendment
in other words you know defamation laws
there are some religions or there are
some icons that you may or may not
criticize then you are really eroding
the system you're bringing down the
system yeah in this system is superior
to any other system I've ever seen any
other system in history so our job is
and here's where people like you and me
and Sam and magic are saying it's we've
got to be careful that the government
does not enact laws where some ideas
cannot be criticized and religion is
just an idea it may be to you everything
but to me it's just an idea and all
ideas can be criticized
it makes your idea only stronger but we
not yet we must not challenge the see we
wasn't
erode the system that makes that
possible so I'm I'm a first amendment
fundamentalist if you want if you're
going to be a fundamentalist of some
kind I suppose that that's the one to be
you